і Сергій шкарлет міністр освіти та науки
України вже з нами
в якому суттєво скорочується видатки на
всі сфери крім сектору оборони скільки
передбачено на освіту на чому Вам
доведеться економити А які видатки буде
профінансовано у повному обсязі
Дуже дякую вам за запитання Дуже дякую
за увагу постійно до питання освіти адже
освіта це є інструментом розвитку
можливостей реалізації І взагалі
формування державності в майбутньому Ну
на жаль звісно війна на жаль російський
агресор вимагає від нас певним чином
зосереджуватись
на виключно на військових потребах і це
правильно адже якщо не буде умовно
держави якщо не буде
українців українства то всі інші сфери
вони відходять на інших влади на
сьогодні по видатках на освіті ми маємо
загальнодержавні видатки передбачені за
загальним фондом на суму майже 122
мільярди гривень
це менше ніж у
2022 році приблизно на 32 мільярди але в
2022 рік приблизно цю суму було знято з
нас під час декількох секвестів і
виключно на оборонні
ініціативи на чому будемо економити до
перш за все це
видатки капітальні видатки адже на
сьогодні реально пріоритетом залишається
заробітна плата пріоритетом залишається
забезпечення дітей з особливими
освітніми потребами але при цьому в
пріоритеті ставляться і безпечні умови
для закладів освіти так само нова
субвенція півтора мільярди яка в першу
чергу для опорних шкіл філії опорних
шкіл ку-купних шкіл більше ніж 350 учнів
буде застосовуватись для розробки саме
засобів щодо укриття також окремою
окремою окремим пріоритетом є закупівлю
шкільних адже сьогодні зміна мережі і
велика кількість внутрішньо переміщених
осіб вимагає від нас створити зовсім
інші умови щодо формування і мережі і
підвозу дітей до більш потужної школи
для забезпечення якості освіти Дякую Ну
щодо проекту бюджету там же ж варто
згадати що закладно і субвенцію для
місцевої влади в розмірі 1,5 млрд грн
облаштування саме укритті у школах це
дуже важливе питання з огляду на так З
огляду
історичні умови які до Це не судиниться
для місцевих це це державна субвенція
Але реально для кожної області до кожної
громади дійсно Я б сказав що вона буде
спрямована на трошки навіть не про
субвенцію А про те чи є все ж таки
моніторинг з боку вашого відомства з
боку Міністерства щодо роботи цих самих
шкільних закладів шкіл у тих наприклад у
яких немає цих укриттів тому що це
питання Ну якщо не для великих міст а
для населених пунктів є актуальними
ви абсолютно праві є моніторинг має бути
постійний і він є постійний більш того
що я особисто
щотижня виїжджаю на міста в кожній
області для того щоб пересвідчитись в
тому що саме крупні школи саме більше
частина населення має бути забезпечений
укриттям Як ідуть роботи облаштуванню
укриттів яким чином відбувається
евакуація дітей під час повітряних
тривог це навіть важливе питання не
просто не просто укриття як безпека а
безпека в загальному сенсі і безпека
руху до укриттів і розташування укриттів
і ознайомлення батьків щодо де і як їх
дитина перебуває під час повітряної
тривоги і дійсно в якій безпеці вона
находиться і облаштування цих укриттів
наповнення їх їх мінімальним мінімально
дозволеним ДСНС комплектом
тих заходів безпеки які мають бути не
просто це підвал приміщення яма а це є
можуть бути і клас і wi-fi і
стаціонарний телефон і карімати і 15
технічна вода і засоби якоїсь там певної
певного сухо сухого пайку і це туалети
або стаціонарні або білий там ціла низка
вимог які має бути до укриттів в тому
сенсі що сьогодні дитина має не просто
перебувати там вона має перебувати і
навчатися в цьому Криті
вони Сергію Давайте поговоримо про
нещодавно звільнені території Харківщини
яке в нас перспективи що нормальне
відносно нормальне навчання поновиться
там чи є сьогодні можливість
організувати Його в онлайн форматі з
огляду на те що ці території залишаються
прифронтовими
Я вам дуже дякую за запитання саме
завжди увазі Міністерства освіти і науки
починаючи навіть з 24
лютого вже ми робили акцент на
організацію освітнього процесу на всіх
на всій території України ми не
розглядаємо її як захоплена окупована ми
розглядаємо як територія суверенної
України особливості зараз коли збройні
сили України
героїчно відбивають нашу землю
повертають в суверенний суверенне
імунітет Наші всі землі Наші всі громади
територіальні перше завдання
Міністерства освіти налагодити освітній
процес ми починаємо терміново ми завжди
терміново організовуємо в всі заклади
всі заходи щодо організації освітнього
процесу на будь-якій суверенній
території України сьогодні онлайн освіта
відбувається майже постійно інші та інше
питання там де необхідно терміново
запровадити виплати зарплати там де вони
ще не були терміново сформувати
керівників шкіл терміново сформувати
освітню систему на тих де окупованих
територіях там де рашисти На жаль Ну ви
знаєте там були і катування освітян там
були і певні певні такі тортури які і
моральні фізичні які до освітян
застосовувались на сьогодні наше
завдання повернути дітей до освітнього
процесу України демократичного
незалежного суверенного і ми це зробимо
і робимо вже і зробимо
пан міністр ну високі візити є мають
конкретний з'їзд для всіх нас от
нещодавно була вкотре президентка
єврокомісія Руслана фонделяйн Минулого
тижня на анонсувала виділення 100
мільйонів євро на відновлення шкіл в
Україні за вашими оцінками шкіл які були
пошкоджені від так російськими ракетами
за вашими оцінками в яку би ви оцінили
суму щодо загальних потреб для
відновлення цих навчальних закладів
дійсно була на минулому тижні десь два
тижні 1 вересня в нас був віце-президент
євро комісії це маргариті есхіна з яким
ми говорили якраз по
формуванню підготовці цього візиту він
відвідав із школи нашої і відвідав інші
заклади освіти і на на підставі цього
саме формувалася взагалі політика
Євросоюзу щодо підтримки галузі освіти
хочу нагадати що у нас сьогодні
2532 школи
пошкоджено з них 287 повністю зруйновано
і це велике трагедія адже якщо Брати по
мінімум мінімум на сьогодні один заклад
освіти при російській агресії страждає і
пошкоджується від ракет снарядів від
пострілів від всього іншого за останніми
підрахунками в наш наша Взагалі
українська потреба на підтримку освіти і
на питання освіти становить більше 9
мільярдів гривень з них яких терміново
нам на сьогодні потрібно більше ніж 2,8
млрд ці потреби включають і відбудову
опалення дахи на
забезпечення необхідними меблями
методичної матеріалами і всі інші
заклади Заходи які на сьогодні мають
бути мають бути забезпечені для того щоб
освітня система пошкоджених закладів
освіти формувалась і працювала повному
обсязі в нас найбільших витрат у нас
дійсно це Харківська Донецька Луганська
Запорізька Миколаївська Херсонська
область і саме більше туди витрат
необхідно для покриття збитків галузі
освіти
ми вже на сьогодні працюємо причому не
тільки просто за умовно кажучи зі школи
але Працюємо з дитячими садочками
відпрацюємо з закладами позашкільної
освіти Ми працюємо в університетами
колесами про тих освітою закладами
просто освіти в цілому 9,2 мільярда це
загальні загальний рівень пошкоджень яка
зазнала освіта від російської агресії
вступна кампанія в Україні майже
завершилася Чи можемо ми підбити
підсумки скільки випускників у нас стали
студентами і Які спеціальності
найпопулярніші цього року
Дуже дякую за запитання на жаль до кінця
вище підсумки підбити вступної кампанії
не може у вас скільки в нас ще вступ до
магістратури відбувається з 12 по 16
серпня В нас відбувалася спеціальна
сесія по національному мультику
предметному тесту я пишаюсь тим що
навіть спеціально сесію в нас Майже 4800
дітей 800 учасників складало
національний мультиплектний тести Саме
ці діти які забажали навчатися в
закладах вищої освіти України в цілому
буде 209 тисяч у нас складало на
основний додаткову сесію 4,800 учасників
4800 у нас складала в додаткову сесію і
якщо розрахувати то приблизно 214 000 з
20024 тисяч випускників 11 класів цього
року пройшло національний мультиплектний
тест тобто обрали в подальшому в відео
закладі вищої освіти України на сьогодні
за попередніми даними в нас зараховано
закладів саме вищий до університетів я
не рахую коледжі не рахую про в тих
освіти 131 000
абітурієнтів зараховані До закладів
вищої освіти України з них понад 56
тисяч цей бюджет і з них майже 11 тисяч
дітей за квотою два тобто потенційно
небезпечних територій з окупованих
територій Донбасу Криму це рекордна
кількість яка взагалі за ці вісім років
була зарахована дітей з тимчасового
окупованих територій в минулому році
було 2004 особи сьогодні майже 11 тисяч
спеціальності які які сьогодні найбільш
стрибуні Ну мені тішить що це і середня
освіта мене тішить що це і медицина
Комп'ютерні науки це висо екологічні
спеціальності інженерія програмного
забезпечення філологія будівництво - це
цивільна інженерія тобто в топі ті
спеціальності які майбутні майбутні
фахівці українців розцінюють як такі що
буде спрямована на відбудову нашої
держави на побудову зовсім її іншого
ступеня іншого рішення
хочу сказати по вступної кампанії Я одну
хвилинку Якщо нам дозволяє ефір
національний мультипрідний тест в нас
також і передбачений не просто
національний мультиплектний там
магістерський тест навчальної
компетенції і
магістерський фаховий тест по по вступу
до вже до
магістратури в нас ті хто не
Зареєструвався може мати можливість ще
сьогодні 19 вересня
зареєструватись в підсумкову на
нововведення спеціальної сесії яка
запланована з 29 вересня до 3 жовтня
зрозуміло па технологією Дякуємо вам
бажаємо успіху усім нашим новоспеченим
студентам і ті хто планує ними стати і
сподіваємося що їхнє навчання дуже скоро
перейде в нормальний мирний процес
Сергій шкарлет міністр освіти та науки
України був з нами на ці